bitcoin vous en avez peut-être déjà
entendu parler mais probablement vous ne
savez pas exactement de quoi il en
retourne
alors qu'est ce que le bitcoin est bien
c'est ce qu'on va essayer de découvrir
ensemble ce soir
mais avant de commencer j'aimerais vous
poser une question
vous qui êtes là et je vais vous
demander de répondre franchement
j'aimerais savoir qui parmi vous pensent
que le bitcoin est une escroquerie
intellectuelle
une sorte de tulipes 2.0
très bien qui n'a pas vraiment d'opinion
sur le sujet et enfin qui pensent au
contraire que le bitcoin est précurseur
d'une révolution technologique très
importante
ok très bien alors quand on pense à
bitcoin le le premier mot qui vient à
l'esprit
ces monnaies effectivement le bitcoin
est une monnaie une monnaie 100%
digitale
mais ce n'est pas seulement ça c'est
aussi une technologie qui existe dans le
tissu internet et qui existent sans
serveur central et qui permet à deux
personnes d'échanger des valeurs dans le
monde entier de façon efficace rapide et
un coût très réduit mais pour mieux
comprendre comment feront vite quand une
fonctionne intéressons nous d'abord aux
monnaies que nous connaissons les
monnaies traditionnelles comme l'euro
par exemple pour exister pour
fonctionner l'euro où le dollar ou tout
monnaies traditionnelles se base sur
deux entités importante indispensable
une banque centrale qui va établir la
politique monétaire est un état qui par
sa légitimité historique et culturel est
aussi son arsenal juridique va créer la
confiance dans cette monnaie notamment
et bien en l'incluant dans la loi en en
faisant la monnaie unique et obligatoire
alors une des premières conséquences
c'est de rajouter d influence
géopolitique à cette monnaie et donc
toutes les monnaies que nous connaissons
sont à plus ou moins grande échelle et
bien des monnaies locales le bitcoin lui
n'a ni banque centrale ni entité
juridique il est tout seul il se suffit
à lui-même en quelque sorte
pour autant il faut de la confiance il
faut des règles
alors comment est ce que ça fonctionne
bitcoin se base sur une science fiable
et exacte les mathématiques la
cryptographie tous les éléments sur
lesquels reposent bitcoin sont des
éléments mathématiques la politique
monétaire par exemple une équation
mathématique
cette courbe que vous voyez et qui
ressemble étrangement à la courbe
d'extraction d'une ressource sera
abondante au début est de plus en plus
difficiles à extraire au fur et à mesure
du temps indique qu'il n'y aura jamais
plus de 21 millions de bitcoin en
existence 21 millions ça chiffre qui est
arbitraire mais qui ne pourra jamais
changer qui inscrit dans l'adn de
bitcoin pourquoi est ce qu'il ne pourra
jamais changer parce qu'on ne peut pas
acquérir et mathématiques
on ne peut pas pirater les mathématiques
virait si numéris la force dans les
nombres les mathématiques sont
incorruptibles
ce qui fait que bitcoin lui-même est
incorruptible vous aurez vos pointé une
arme sur une équation mathématique 2 et
2 font toujours quatre pour fonctionner
en tant que système de paiement bitcoin
repose sur internet il est constitué de
dizaines de milliers de serveurs qui
font tourner le logiciel bitcoin que
n'importe qui peut installer c'est un
logiciel libre et ouvert et ses serveurs
se connaître les uns aux autres
directement en pair-à-pair sans aucun
serveur central le réseau se reconfigure
en permanence ainsi si vous vouliez
arrêté
bitcoin ou l'interdire la seule solution
serait d'éteindre internet à tout jamais
le rôle de ces serveurs
c'est de distribuer synchronisée et
maintenir une base de données un grand
livre comptable qui contient
l'intégralité de toutes les transactions
depuis la création du réseau et à chaque
fois qu'une nouvelle transaction est mis
sur le réseau on en a à peu près cent
mille pages par jour actuellement le
réseau ses serveurs se synchronise à
part un système assez complexe
d'élections
et met à jour cette base de données
ayant encore une fois sur des principes
mathématiques assure que la base de
données qui est présente qui est
synchronisé partout correspondre à la
vérité de toutes les transactions et
cette base de données ne peut pas être
modifiée il ya des preuves mathématiques
qui démontre que ce que vous voyez
correspond aux bonnes transactions il
n'est pas possible de les modifier
et encore une fois c'est ce qui fait la
confiance de bitcoin la confiance de
bitcoin est basé sur les mathématiques
sur des principes mathématiques
si on veut regarder un peu à quoi
ressemble cette base de données
ce grand livre comptable on pourrait en
faire une vision un petit peu naïve sous
la forme d'un tableau qui montrent en
fait qui possède quoi combien combien en
fait c'est un chiffre un nombre en
bitcoin dont on voit qu'il est divisible
et qui est bien cette espèce de nombre
racontent numérotée un peu votre rib un
peu l'adresse que vous allez donner à
quelqu'un si vous voulez qu'il vous
plaît on a là un système qui à la fois
complètement transparent
l'intégralité des transactions du réseau
sont visibles par tout le monde
les soldes sont visibles par tout le
monde et qui en même temps et pseudo
anonyme puisque les comptes que vous
voyez là et bien ne sont pas rattachés à
10 et à des identités l'état civil
n'existe pas dans l'it cogne il n'a
juste aucun sens à ces adresses
publiques
ce ribes sont attachés des votes parce
qu'ils sont tellement compliquées et
l'on est impossible à retenir qu'en
général on les a sous la forme d'un
fichier informatique ou alors imprimé
sur un morceau de papier
on appelle ça des clés privées et ça
fonctionne exactement comme un bon
porteur celui qui possède la clé privée
à la possibilité de signer une
transaction et dépenser les bitcoins
attaché à l'adresse quand on possède une
clé privée
on possède des bitcoins et la possession
dans bitcoin est très très importante
regardez par exemple cette carte à puce
cette carte à puce elle contient mais
que les privés qui me permette à accéder
à mes bitcoin n'importe quand quand je
le veux
et non seulement je suis le seul au
monde à pouvoir accéder à ces bitcoin
puisque je suis le seul à connaître la
clé privée mais personne ne peut
m'empêcher d'accéder à ces bitcoin
puisqu'il n'y a pas d'intermédiaire
je les possède vraiment voici maintenant
une autre carte à puce que vous
connaissez probablement mieux elle aussi
me donne accès à la possibilité de
dépenser
il ya une grande différence c'est que je
peux accéder à mon compte à mes oraux
avec la bienveillance de visa de ma
banque de la banque de france de l'état
français de bruxelles et finalement de
la banque centrale européenne ce n'est
pas de l'argent que je possède à
n'importe quel moment quelqu'un peut me
couper l'accès à cet argent c'est la
différence entre de l'argent dette et de
l'argent valeur et si vous pensez que
ces différences est juste un petit peu
lointaine où trivial vient demander à
nos amis chypriote ce qu'ils en pensent
alors maintenant qu'on sait un petit peu
plus comment bitcoin fonctionne
interrogeons nous sur la notion de
monnaie pour fonctionner correctement
une monnaie doit obéir un certain nombre
de caractéristiques on va s'intéresser
plus particulièrement à trois et on va
comparer lors le dollar et le bitcoin
pour fonctionner une monnaie doit être
reconnue accepté lors a traversé les
âges des probablement ou que vous alliez
avec l'or vous pourrez acheter quelque
chose
le dollar aussi bien entendu c'est une
monnaie globale mondiale mais qui est
quand même attaché un certain nombre à
d'attache géopolitique qui font que
peut-être dans certains pays ce sera
plus compliqué le bitcoin lui même si
aujourd'hui il est utilisé par des
grandes entreprises comme microsoft ou
expedia qui a cent mille marchant dans
le monde qu'ils utilisent
il est assez peu probable que vous
arriviez à trouver un marchand qu'il
accepte dans la rue ou ailleurs mais ça
ne peut que progresser portable ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire pour être pas
capables de dépenser en fait son argent
sur internet pour pouvoir acheter
quelque chose dans le monde entier lors
bon c'est difficile
d'acheter de commander sur amazon avec
un lingot donc on va dire ça marche pas
le dollar il y a les cartes de crédit il
y a
paypal vous pouvez l'utiliser partout ça
fonctionne bien le bitcoin lui c'est la
monnaie de l'internet
tout le monde peut l'utiliser à partir
du moment où le marchand décide de
l'accepter on peut transférer les
valeurs comme ça immédiatement une
monnaie aussi pour fonctionner doit être
rare lors lui il a une masse qui est
masse totale qui est limité il est rare
on sait qu'on pourra pas doubler la
masse totale de l'ordre du jour au
lendemain le bitcoin lui comme on l'a vu
sur la courbe il a été créé pour être
rare c'est un peu la définition de la
rareté
il a été fait pour ça est ce que le
dollar ra peut se poser la question
alors pour voir ça on va regarder la
courbe des missions du dollar depuis
1918 à 2007 donc on voit qu'on passe de
quelques milliards à 8 100 milliards
donc on sait que le coût de la vie
augmente qui est une inflation mais
laissez moi vous poser une question à
nouveau à votre avis qu'est ce sur quoi
le dollar et il indexés
est-ce que c'est sur l'argent le platine
ou alors lors alors qu'ils pensent que
c'est sur l'argent par exemple qui
pensent que c'est sur le platine et
enfin qui pensent que c'est sur l'or
alors évidemment c'était une question
piège depuis 1971
l'étalon or n'existe plus et le dollar
repose est indexé sur rien du tout alors
on voit effectivement qu'à une petite
augmentation à partir de ce moment là
mais tout à l'air d'être sur contrôle
sous contrôle n'est ce pas sauf que ma
courbe s arrête en 2007
alors on va regarder ce qui se passe en
2008 2012 2015
sur les sept dernières années la masse
totale du dollar a été multipliée par
cinq
cela revient à imprimé 15 mille dollars
par seconde pour répondre à la question
on peut dire que le dollar non n'est pas
une ressource rare puisque on peut en
imprimé visiblement à l'infini
alors la question qui vient après c'est
pourquoi pourquoi une monnaie qui
existent en dehors des états est ce que
c'est juste pour répondre un rêve
libertarien ou est ce qu'il ya une autre
raison un petit peu plus profonde
derrière tout ça il est certain que pour
nous européens qui avons accès à la
banque a tout ce qu'il faut
le bitcoin ne va pas vraiment changé
notre quotidien ou résoudre des
problèmes que nous avons mais nous ne
sommes pas seuls sur terre dans le monde
deux personnes sur trois en âge de
travailler n'ont pas accès à la banque
ou à des moyens de paiement fiable
deux personnes sur trois ne peuvent pas
participer à l'économie mondialisée dont
on parle tant le bitcoin puisqu'il
existe sans frontières puisque tout le
monde peut y accéder simplement en ayant
à l'accès internet est un téléphone
facebook google en train de couvrir la
terre firefox présente maintenant des
téléphones qui coûte pas cher
n'importe qui bientôt pourra participer
à l'économie globale mais c'est pas tout
bitcoin en plus d'être une monnaie est
une technologie et propose de faire de
l'argent programmables on peut attacher
à bitcoin un certain nombre de
propriétés des programmes informatiques
qui permettent de créer de nouvelles
applications et la technologie qui en
dessous de bitcoin permettra même à
terme de remplacer des métiers comme
celui de banquiers notaires pourquoi pas
avocats et même repenser la manière dont
les entreprises ou les gouverneurs
gouvernement sont créés existe et
fonctionne mais aujourd'hui où est ce
qu'on en est bitcoin c'est un petit peu
comme internet en 1995
c'est une technologie qui est pas trés
compris qui est très complexe et dont on
se pose vraiment la question de son
utilité
si vous avez un peu plus d'un certain
âge rappelez vous il ya 20 ans est ce
que vous pensiez vraiment qu'internet
allait changer révolutionner votre vie
vous qui maintenant ne pouvait
probablement plus envisager de
communiquer ou travailler sur votre
iphone
bitcoin c'est pareil on en est au même
niveau
sauf que c'est quand même une industrie
qui se développe de plus en plus des
centaines de milles
on de dollars sont investis dans ses
infrastructures dans ces startups des
milliers de développeurs entrepreneurs
ingénieurs s'intéresse à bitcoin il y en
a même qui quittent des entreprises
prestigieuses comme google ou facebook
pour s'impliquer dans bitcoin pour poser
dès aujourd'hui les graines d'un
changement économique et sociale
radicale de demain merci